si vous avez une hypothèque et que vous
devez bientôt la renouveler vous jongler
possiblement entre un taux fixe et un
trou variable pas facile de choisir
quand on sait pas exactement ce que la
Banque du Canada nous réserve et qui a
aussi quand même à 8 reprises son taux
directeur en un an alors que choisir
tofix ou taux variable pour du court ou
du long terme bien des questions on va
tenter d'y voir clair avec Youssef
gueulance fondateur de ducs finances
bonjour Youssef d'abord le parlons de la
répercussion de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt sur le portefeuille des
Québécois des Canadiens mais en fait
tout d'abord il faut savoir que la
banque du scandale lance le taux pour
lutter contre l'inflation donc ce qu'on
veut faire en sorte c'est de réduire le
coût de l'emprunt donc tout ce qui est
prêt personnel marge de crédit prêt aux
entreprises les taux d'intérêt ont
augmenté pour ce type de particulier là
où ce type de personnes là et à
l'inverse les taux sur les épargnes donc
on pense au compte d'épargne au CPG
certificat placement garanti aux
obligations donc ceux qui veulent
investir de façon plus prudente mais eux
aussi pas leur taux d'intérêt augmenté
donc ça profite pour une partie de la
population puis une autre qui voit que
le coût de l'emprunt a augmenté et pour
les nouveaux acheteurs nouveaux
acheteurs de maison commencent tous les
affecter donc ça c'est aussi un gros
répercussion ça c'est un impact sur le
marché de l'immobilier on le sent tout
de suite c'est que le coût pour
emprunter donc pour se qualifier pour
une première propriété ou l'achat d'une
propriété c'est que la valeur de
l'hypothèque auquel on se qualifie
devient plus petit pourquoi parce que on
nous qualifie avec un taux d'intérêt qui
est plus élevé donc il y a fortement
augmenté depuis la dernière année et ce
que ça fait c'est que avant ben on a
bientôt directeur à point 25 donc on
pouvait aller chercher une propriété
exemple si on a un revenu familial de
100 000 donc vous pouvez aller chercher
jusqu'à 485 000 de valeur d'hypothèque
alors qu'aujourd'hui avec le taux
directeur qui a 4.5 pour le même revenu
la même situation financière c'est un
montant de seulement 410000 donc une
baisse de 75000 dollars de la valeur de
l'hypothèque en seulement exactement
puis la valeur des propriétés on voit le
nombre de de vente là qui ont baissé
pratiquement 40% une année donc les
effets sont là et là avec le
renouvellement hypothécaire qui peut
peut-être arriver pour bien des gens là
printemps ou au début de l'été est-ce
qu'on devrait opter et ça c'est la
question la question clé tofix ou taux
variable mais en fait la réponse souvent
financée ça dépend donc ça dépend des
besoins des personnes donc si une
personne cherche la stabilité donc je
pense entre autres au premier acheteur
je pense aux gens qui ont un budget un
peu plus serré évidemment le taux fixe
ça permet justement d'avoir une certaine
tranquillité puis de bien dormir la nuit
ce qu'il faut savoir par contre à
l'inverse c'est que le taux variable
présentement il est moins avantageux
mais sur le long terme sur des langues
périodes le taux variable est plus
économique dans 90% du temps donc
quelqu'un qui veut économiser mais qui
est prêt à vivre avec une fluctuation
des taux ben forcément ça va un impact
vous ne l'avez préparé exactement donc
les dernières années donc disons avant
2022 les taux tournaient autour qui
soient au taux fixes aux variables à
deux points présentement quelqu'un qui
hop pour un tout fixe pour un 5 ans on
va avoir un taux à peu près à
84%. et ce qu'on voit c'est forcément ça
a un impact direct sur les versements
hypothécaires donc sur une hypothèque de
300 000 on voit une augmentation d'à peu
près 384 dollars par mois donc à peu
près 125 dollars par tranche de 100000
d'hypothèques là d'augmentation et à
l'inverse on note pour un taux variable
donc là comme j'ai dit on va opter pour
un peu plus élevé mais en espérant que
les taux vont diminuer donc c'est un peu
les anticipations qu'on fait c'est d'ici
la fin de l'année peut-être l'année
prochaine quand la situation va un peu
plus se stabiliser et que la Banque du
Canada va peut-être réduire les taux
mais on va espérer qu'on va économiser
lorsque il y aura des baisses
qui est intéressant dans votre temps
peut-être que la Banque du Canada va
réduire les taux on n'en sait rien pour
l'instant non non c'est rien par contre
c'est un peu le jeu de prendre justement
entre tout fixe ovariable c'est ce qu'on
est prêt à assumer une fluctuation de
taux ou pas il faut savoir aussi les
pénalités il y a une grosse différence
dans le calcul de la pénalité entre un
taux fixe une variable dans le cas Netto
variable c'est trois mois d'intérêt
seulement dans le cas d'un taux fixe
c'est la différentielle de taux donc ça
peut être beaucoup plus d'argent
lorsqu'on brise une hypothèque et qu'on
a signé un contrat de 3 4 5 ans ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher en termes de
pénalités
est-ce qu'il y a une analyse que vous
pouvez faire par rapport à ça aussi donc
les gens qui hésitent peut-être un
conseil qu'on pourrait donner c'est soit
opté pour une échéance fixe mais court
terme justement pour essayer de voir
s'il est au vent baisser ou carrément
d'opter pour les deux les gens savent
pas mais des fois on peut diviser notre
hypothèque en deux et avoir une tranche
à tout fixe une tranche à tout variable
si on est trop indécis sinon il y a des
produits comme des taux variables à
versement fixes donc là on a le même
versement mais on va avoir une portion
nous intérêts qui va changer ou des taux
plafonnés donc là on va avoir un taux
variable avec un taux qui va être
maximisé est-ce que ça vaut la peine de
magasiner l'hypothèque voilà donc là si
on hésite très très important de
magasiner parce qu'il y a des grosses
différences au niveau des taux des fois
le on reçoit une lettre de la pour un
renouvellement taux et c'est des fois
c'est des taux beaucoup trop élevés et
puis des fois les gens signent sans même
avoir pris le temps de magazine
alors que nous a vraiment donné le
meilleur produit alors que quand on va
regarder ailleurs de plus en plus elle
est banques virtuelles aussi qui offrent
des taux super avantageux avec des
produits aussi au niveau des calculs des
pénalités qui peuvent être plus
flexibles oui des banques virtuelles en
fait c'est des prêteurs virtuels souvent
ils sont soutenus aussi par par des
banques traditionnelles donc il y a
beaucoup de concurrence dans le domaine
peut-être un conseil qu'on peut donner
c'est de rencontrer un courtier
hypothécaire qui a accès justement et
aux banques transitionnelles et aux
banques virtuelles donc à ce moment-là
lui fait ce magasin là pour nous il va
comparer les différents taux les
différents produits et c'est digne de
confiance Youssef
parce que ils sont rémunérés justement à
travers les produits
sont soutenus par par les banques par
contre c'est important de lire les
contrats parce que des fois les banques
virtuelles peut-être moins de services
vu qu'il y a pas de succursale mais
l'économie qui réalise sur justement les
coûts d'opération mais ils peuvent
offrir des taux plus compétitifs donc là
prendre le temps vraiment de regarder le
contrat de consulter un professionnel de
bien s'entourer mais c'est un
investissement parce que des fois c'est
des écarts de points 3.5% qu'on peut
aller chercher sur une valeur
d'hypothèque et sur plusieurs années
c'est des milliers de dollars d'économie
donc ça vaut la pause
de cristal qui fonctionne vraiment
j'aimerais en avoir une aussi pour
savoir ce que l'avenir nous réserve mais
Youssef merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateur de dire finance et
puis professeur de finance au Collège
Montmorency merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI